comme chaque jour depuis plus de deux
semaines s'est assis sur sa chaise
sylvain redou poursuit sa grève de la
faim sur le trottoir de la
sous-préfecture d'avesnes-sur-helpe dans
le département du nord
le patron de bar demandent justice après
la fermeture administrative de son
établissement
deux mois de fermeture pour port
irrégulier du masque de clients mais
également pour des bagarres à proximité
de son bar il dénonce un acharnement des
pouvoirs publics et une justice de
copinage aujourd'hui on sanctionne pas
ceux qui se battent
on sanctionne le patron d'établissement
alors si les forces de l'ordre arrivent
au moment d'une bagarre je pense que
c'est plus à eux de sanctionner ce
qu'ils ont mis le désordre parce que
c'est pas le patron comme il désordre
ouais je me révolte je me révolte parce
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est plus au temps
des rois
les élus qui sont à la disposition de la
population des commerçants des artisans
et des chefs d'entreprise cette
fermeture est ému un grand nombre
d'habitués et d'anonymes qui lui ont
apporté leur soutien à travers une
pétition lancée sur les réseaux sociaux
parmi ses premiers soutiens karine sa
compagne quand elle n'est pas auprès de
lui elle s'occupe tant bien que mal de
son bar vidé de ses clients au delà de
l'incompréhension elle a aujourd'hui
peur pour la santé de son patron
bah il est faible donc c'est il arrive à
son 17e jour de grève de la faim ou la
pas manger du tout là il a du mal il
commence à avoir un peu de mal à boire
donc j'essaye d'être plus possible avec
clive ne pas le laisser seul on n'est
pas à l'abri de quoi que ce soit mais ne
veut pas lâcher
mais voilà côté administration cette
décision semble bel et bien justifié à
la sous-préfecture d'avesnes-sur-helpe
la grève de la faim du patron de bar
n'est pas passée inaperçue concernant
cette grève de la faim je tiens tout
d'abord à dire que on a une attention
particulière par rapport à cette
situation sa chaleur et que à ma demande
les sapeurs pompiers viennent
régulièrement pour pouvoir vérifier
l'état de centaines monsieur recrues à
l'origine de cette décision
administrative
le service public se justifie l'arrêté
de fermeture administrative qui a été
pris a été motivée par un certain nombre
d'éléments
tout d'abord les services de la
gendarmerie ou constaté plusieurs
altercations et bagarres devant cet
établissement est il
ont également pu relever la non
distanciation sociale et surtout le non
respect des mesures sanitaires et en
l'occurrence le port du masque à la
mairie de fourmies l'after est connue de
tous
un lieu décrit comme convivial qui
constitue néanmoins des troubles à
l'ordre public et ce de manière répétée
la sous préfecture a proposé deux mois
de fermeture administrative
moi je suis intervenu auprès du
sous-préfet de façon à ce qu'ils
puissent sur le cloud s'expliquer de
vive voix ce qui a été fait puisque il a
été reçu par la secrétaire général tout
début août
ça avait relativement modifier les
choses puisque le sous-préfet proposé à
l'époque 15 jours de fermeture
administrative
sauf contre le 15 août et le 15
septembre il semble qu'il y a eu quatre
à cinq interventions des gendarmes
ce qui fait que le bas du coup il s'est
pris deux mois déterminé à aller
jusqu'au bout de son combat
sylvain roux dénonce un ras-le-bol
général et des conditions de travail
devenues insupportables pour les
commerçants et chefs d'entreprise de sa
région je lâcherai pas parce qu'au fait
c'est mon mari meurt je remue air avec
l'administration française un peu patins
peut pas se permettre de prendre la
décision de la continuité de la
pérennité du bar on peut plus continuer
comme ça les français en ont marre
les françaises en ont marre les gens qui
travaillent en ont ras-le-bol face à
cette décision sylvain redou a déposé un
recours débouté par le tribunal
administratif d'affaires doit
prochainement être jugée sur le fond
dernier rempart pour éviter la faillite